what if you're not good at anything so I
got this question for one of my YouTube
viewers love you guys
the halo Spirit who wrote an essay what
if you are not really good at anything
this is a really important question and
a lot of people out there may be feeling
like you don't have the skills to launch
a business and you don't know where to
start
here's the thing this is really
important it doesn't matter if you don't
have the skills or the talent okay that
doesn't matter what you need to find is
the passion you've got to find something
that you are passionate about that you
can wake up in the morning get excited
about doing and if you haven't figured
that out yet then you kind of go and
explore try things try something and see
if you like it see if it sticks or not
and if it does then you'll find a way to
turn it into a business you'll find a
way to get better at it you'll get
better at because you love doing it
you're going to do it every day you're
going to get better at you can't help it
you can only build the business around
something that you are extremely
passionate what's the most important
rule in business nothing else will save
you if you don't love what you're doing
so to give you some examples when I was
in my early 20s I my girlfriend and I
broke up and she hated dancing and I
love dancing I thought hey this is a
chance for me to go out in and learn to
dance and I started doing salsa dancing
and if you looked at that as a rational
thing to do say why haven't you
shouldn't do salsa dancing you know
you're you're too tall you don't have
the rhythm you didn't grow up with it
it'll take forever to learn the body
movements you don't understand Spanish
you don't even know what the music
sounds like you know your steps will be
too big you shouldn't take salsa but it
was something that I wanted to do just I
don't know I didn't think about it from
a logical rational point of view it was
more something that I was excited to try
and give it a shot and see what happened
and it turned out that I fell in love
with it I fell in love with the music I
found on with the people I fell in love
with the community and eventually became
a business opportunity and I'm going to
investor in the largest salsa school
maybe in North America I'm a DJ I
part-time instructor what I want to it's
a lot of fun and it's become a
big part of my life and the people who
are around me are from a lot of them are
from the salsa community so you were
something that I wasn't very good at I
knew nothing about all the odds were
against me and they turned it into a
successful business opportunity but also
something that gives me a lot of
personal fulfillment and was only by
exploring my passion at the same time I
things I tried ballroom dancing I tried
rock climbing and and those things
weren't interesting for me those things
weren't exciting for me and so I stopped
like rock climbing I went once tried it
out didn't like it
that I'm done with rock climbing for
some people it's great it's just not for
me
some of the things that I picked up I
picked up snowboarding recently and you
know when I first learned it I was going
almost every day big learning curve
loved it now I still like it but it's
not a deep-seated passion like I can't
wait to get on the snowboarding Hill
again right so that's not going to be
something I'm going to build a business
around at least not yet and so you'll
find that some things you try and and
you know you don't like and so you stop
and some things you try for a while you
do like them and then it starts to fade
and so that's not something that you're
going to build a business around either
you got to find the things that you love
doing that you wake up you're excited to
do that's when you can build a business
around get really good at and also help
other people when you find that you know
you've hit the mark and until then have
the courage to keep exploring because
it's hard it's hard when you don't know
what you want to do and you feel like
this next thing has to be the thing that
gets me everything right you put so much
pressure and everything you feel like a
total failure from bouncing from one
thing to another
but it's important part of your journey
in your process and when you find it as
with all matters of the heart you'll
know and that's the opportunity to run
after believe those you watch the video
thumbs up below leave a comment ask the
question below those means so much to me
it keeps me going every day and if you
want to see videos like this click on my
face subscribe to the channel thank you
so much I'll see you soon
you